- Hi, I'm Keke Palmer,
and I'm here to give
you some acting nopes,
and I'll throw in some yeps too.
(upbeat music)
Early to set is a absolute nope.
I hate having to come to work early.
I really do.
If I do have to come early,
then I try to bring like
a blanket in the car.
You know what I mean?
On the way, so I can try to sleep,
or in my trailer,
I try to sleep in the makeup trailer.
I try to sleep until
I have to work on set.
So yeah, it's an absolute nope.
(upbeat music)
Improvisation without prompting,
it's a yep.
You know, I mean, I, I
definitely prefer to know
if somebody wants me to do
improv because I actually
really respect, you know,
obviously a writer's word.
So I don't wanna add to it
if it shouldn't be added to,
but I do love to improv
and I can have fun,
but I just like to get
the signal that it's cool
so I don't disrespect
the words on the page.
(upbeat music)
Oh, nope, no, you do not
disobey what the animal
trainer has said.
Absolutely not.
Yeah.
When that happened in the
movie, I'm like, mm-mm girl, no,
that's why you can't do that.
You have to really be, you
know, respectful of their job
because they know these
animals and they know how
the animals want to be approached.
You cannot disrespect
them and, and what they're
doin' because that's when things go wrong.
So yeah, I definitely always
take my lead from the animal
wranglers and know what I need to do
when I don't need to do it.
(calming music)
Ignoring continuity is a absolute nope.
Okay, I come from the
old school where yes,
I let the prop people do they job,
I let everybody do their resets,
but it's to the point where
I will self reset as well
because I really take pride in continuity
and things like that,
it's one of the first
things I learned on set.
I did a movie with William
H. Macy, called The Wool Cap,
when I was 10, in Montreal.
And, I remember, you know, I
was like, what are you doin'
askin' the people that kept
bringing everything back?
And they said, this is
continuity, you know,
and they explained to me
Scripty and all that stuff.
And so, ever since then, I
always took such pride in it.
So yeah, you gotta pay attention.
(upbeat music)
Only being sorta off
book is a absolute nope.
Okay?
The only thing I'm sorta on
is, like, the performance
that I'm gonna choose, but
you've gotta know those lines
if you expect to do a
performance or have a,
have a collaboration
with the director on what
the performance could or
couldn't be, you know,
you have to know the lines
'cuz if you don't know
the lines then how you gonna play with it?
You know, you gonna be too busy
worried about what the
lines are, you know?
And I don't wanna hold up our whole crew,
have everybody there for hours and hours
'cause I didn't study my
lines the night before,
that's crazy.
(upbeat music)
Makin' friends with
Crafty is absolute yup.
Yeah, like why not?
You know what I mean?
Especially if you guys like end up
really gettin' to know each other
then they can give you
like some special treats,
special little sandwiches, you know.
But yeah, it's great.
I mean Crafty is like the
unsung hero on every set.
(upbeat music)
Phoning in anything on
set is a absolute nope.
You cannot do this.
No, no, no.
Because it's like marking a dance step,
if you mark it the whole way,
then when it's time to really perform
you're gonna be marking it.
So, you know, you can't phone it in.
Now, yes, you don't
wanna tire yourself out,
but you have to be true
to it at least a couple
of times with your director
so you guys can really
get into the vibe of it,
and then if you need to take
a break 'cuz you don't wanna
overuse your muscle in that
moment, that's understandable,
but phoning it in totally,
no, no, no.
I'm Keke Palmer and this
has been Acting Nopes.